[Applaudissements]
2019 la France découvre avec effroi une
par sombre de Christian Quesada gagnant
historique des 12 Coups de Midi le
champion des jeux télé mis en examen
pour pédophilie à 3 ans de prison mais
en 2021 il bénéficie d'une liberté
conditionnelle et tente de vivre dans
l'anonymat il a changé de l'eau
une barbe
il se veut méconnaissable cette liberté
conditionnée elle était soumise à
certaines obligations que l'homme
n'aurait pas respecté il a donc été
interpellé hier et plaçant en détention
à Perpignan alors Christian Quesada
interpellé de retour en prison que
s'est-il passé les révélations de Myriam
Palomba ce soir dans TPMP
et nous sommes donc avec Myriam
merci Myriam d'être avec nous Myriam
Palomba journaliste bien sûr et habitué
de TPMP merci ma chérie d'être là tu es
radieuse vraiment radieuse je dis bien
radio merci Guillaume a des infos
incroyables aussi si vous avez travaillé
en collaboration ça me fait plaisir de
voir cette belle équipe
vous êtes au sommet du journaliste
a été interpellé il s'est fait
interpellé hier en fait alors il a été
interpellé hier et mis tout de suite en
prison dans la maison d'arrêt de
Perpignan en fait parce qu'il n'a pas
respecté les obligations de sa liberté
conditionnelle en fait la liberté
conditionnelle c'est un dispositif qu'on
met en place pour les délinquants
sexuels les criminels sexuels et ils
doivent respecter un certain nombre de
choses comme ne plus approcher des
mineurs se soumettre un contrôle
judiciaire régulier et lui en fait il
n'a pas respecté toutes ces conditions
là donc le juge a estimé qu'il devait
retourner en prison alors
[Musique]
bien quasiment donc du coup ils sont
intervenus rapidement il a été placé à
l'isolement faut le dire tout de suite
et il pourrait faire la fin de sa peine
il avait fait deux ans il avait été
condamné à trois donc il pourrait faire
entre 7 mois et un an de détention là
mais pourquoi il a fait ça parce que il
était il pourrait il a pas respecté les
règles je comprends pas parce que on
soupçonne que en fait vous savez un jour
j'avais dit ici que on l'avait vu près
d'une école dans le Midi d'accord et ça
avait suscité un débat et ben on
soupçonne ça il faut le dire aussi que
Christian Quesada peut-être ne serait
pas exemples de tout reproche
actuellement alors on ne sait pas s'il y
a eu des perquisitions des saisies y
a-t-il d'autres images pédo
pornographiques
et du coup c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
décidés
de nouvelles images de nouvelles images
vraiment sa liberté conditionnelle
exactement pour la liberté financière
non mais là c'est incroyable donc ça
vous étonne enfin il y a quelqu'un de
sensé qui peut dire qu'un monsieur qui a
30000 images pédopornographiques qui
dans son ordinateur on va le libérer un
an et demi faire la moitié de sa peine
et l'interdire de touche d'approcher des
mineurs et il y a quelqu'un de sensé qui
peut dire ça et tout le monde trouve ça
normal
avait déjà le procureur avait reconnu en
fait que la peine était trop légère en
fait il y avait une histoire du covid
les accusés enfin les victimes n'avaient
pas pu venir donc le le jugement avait
été un peu fait à la va vite ça c'est
sûr ça doit être bien pour les victimes
bien sûr d'entendre ça que c'est fait à
la va-vite c'est qu'on a d'autres infos
c'est déjà un récidiviste
2017 il avait pris deux mois de prison
alors en 2003 il avait pris deux mois de
prison avec sursis pour pour exhibition
sexuelle et en 2009 c'était pour
corruption de mineurs sur sur mineur de
plus de 15 ans et pareil des tensions
d'image P2 pornographiques
il a fait que deux ans de prison il ne
pouvait pas s'en sortir comme ça compte
tenu de la gravité des faits corruption
de mineur certes on a mis la main sur
tout le dossier on a vu ce qu'il y avait
dans les clés USB de Christian Quesada
des viols d'enfants de moins de 10 ans
des images vraiment des viols d'enfants
de moins de 10 ans des vidéos
des enfants de moins de 10 ans mais
c'est à gerber ce qu'il y a dans ces
signes voilà il faisait aussi passer on
va parler dans un instant pour des
jeunes filles mineures pour obtenir des
photos pornographiques de jeunes filles
c'est extrêmement grave on sait qu'il y
avait d'autres plaintes qui étaient en
cours donc c'est pas étonnant qui
retourne en prison aujourd'hui alors
vous aurez les infos dans un instant
parce que vous avez eu des infos
vraiment incroyables juste comment les
médias font pour avoir les infos en
général ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
appelle on a je peux pas révéler tous
les secrets mais on est souvent en
contact avec avec des policiers qui nous
donnent qui nous donnent des infos et
puis pareil on appelle les avocats les
gendarmes les policiers sur
des commissariats concernés et on se
renseigne comme ça et aussi souvent
aussi via le parquet on a des infos sur
tout ce sur tout ce genre d'affaires
alors Guillaume les infos on a d'autres
infos et Gilles si tu vas tu vas tu vas
corroborer ces infos de donc on a mis la
main sur deux documents le premier c'est
une lettre qu'il a envoyé à son ex qui
s'appelle Sabrina il dit Sabrina je
souhaite en finir avec mes addictions
elle date de quand cette lettre elle est
récente on peut pas dire exactement
quand il est sorti d'accord de prise
donc c'est vraiment c'est un document
exclusif pour TPMP je souhaite en finir
avec mes addictions qui reconnaît qu'il
y a des addictions je serai en totale
acceptation de la sanction prononcée je
veux te rassurer d'une chose très
importante oui j'ai été sincère avec toi
à tout moment tu es même la seule qui
m'a apporté du mieux être et je serai
toujours très reconnaissant pour cela il
s'en prend aussi à Jean-Luc Reichmann
présentateur des 12 Coups de Midi je
suis assez déçu des réactions de
certaines personnes qui prétendaient
être des amis des témoignages bidons
juste pour briller sans même connaître
la moindre information Reichmann par
exemple qui est bien bien loin de ce que
je pensais et il parle aussi de la vie
qu'il a eu en prison je continue à aller
bien je je dors je lis je regarde le
sport sur Canal+ je t'embrasse et à très
vite Christian ça c'est une aide qu'il
adressait à son ex donc qui s'appelle
Sabrina mais il
a pas ça parce qu'il était énormément
insulté par par tous les prisonniers il
était mis souvent à l'isolement enfin
c'était pas c'était pas une vie tant
mieux pour lui mais c'était pas une vie
facile tant pis pour lui tant pis pour
lui c'était pas une vie une vie facile
on a aussi l'interrogatoire de Christian
Quesada chez le juge sur le sujet de la
corruption de mineur donc alors
justement on va en parler dans un
instant pour ceux qui nous rejoignent à
20h50 Christian Quesada la star des 12
Coups de Midi a été interpellé lundi
immédiatement conduit à la prison de
Perpignan c'est face au non respect de
certaines des obligations de sa liberté
conditionnelle que le juge d'application
des peines a pris cette décision à sa
sortie de prison en liberté
conditionnelle Christian Quesada devait
se soumettre à certaines obligations
comme nous l'a dit Myriam il s'agit d'un
dispositif imposé au délinquant et
criminel sexuel qui prévoit souvent une
obligation de soins ou interdit de
fréquenter des mineurs et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui
Christian Quesada est retourné en prison
pour combien de temps Gilles avant qu'on
ait les infos de Guillaume le reste de
sa peine c'est un an mais avec les
remises de peine automatique ça serait
sept mois
après après effectivement avec Myriam on
se demande si le fait de l'avoir coincé
là juste hier ne signifie pas
effectivement que d'autres procédures
sont en cours on se souvient qu'à
l'époque on procès il y avait eu une
plainte examinée mais il y a d'autres
plaintes il y a d'autres affaires
Guillaume connaît donc du coup est-ce
que c'est pas pour eux une manière de
prévenir d'autres exactions Christian
Quesada c'est la question que tout le
monde se pose ce soir c'est ça qui est
le peut-être le nœud de la faire et puis
soit il voulait fuir soit il y a
d'autres affaires qui vont sortir
des jeunes femmes des jeunes filles via
les réseaux sociaux comme il avait
l'habitude de le faire avec des profils
cachés et du coup c'est aussi pour ça
que que le juge veut vraiment mettre fin
à tout ça tous ces risques Guillaume
justement on a un extrait de
l'interrogatoire sur le sujet de la
corruption de mineur donc Christian
Quesada il crée en fait un faux profil
facebook qui s'appelait Justine Ferrand
qui était une jeune adolescente et ils
sont servaient pour rentrer en contact
avec des jeunes filles mineures donc le
juju lui demande connaissez-vous le
compte Facebook dont le pseudo et
Justine Ferrand oui c'est moi qui l'ai
créé ça faisait plus crédible pour des
jeux auxquels je jouais s'agissais d'île
d'hommes ou de femmes donc qu'est-ce qui
parlait avec de jeunes filles ou de
jeunes garçons des filles jeunes
quelques garçons et un ou deux adultes
c'était du chat à connotation sexuelle
le juge il demande quel était le but de
ces discussions de parler de sexe et
d'obtenir des photos dénudées des photos
des parties intimes et enfin il revient
sur un point très important juste une
Ferrand donc Christian Quesada a proposé
une jeune fille de coucher avec un homme
pour de l'argent un homme célèbre qui
passe à la télé donc on comprend que
c'est Christian Quesada en fait qui a
proposé à une fille de coucher avec
lui-même mais sous une fausse identité
oui c'est du pur fantasme ça ne s'est
passé qu'avec elle et je ne saurais dire
pourquoi j'ai un problème avec la
tranche d'âge 15-21 ans donc il
reconnaît qu'il a attiré par les mineurs
de 15 ans notamment à cause d'événements
de ma vie privée que je n'ai pas réussi
à régler donc c'est ce qu'il a dit au
juste sur le sujet de la corruption
incroyable c'est les infos là
franchement en fait c'est le l'origine
même de l'emprisonnement qui est Sada en
2017 puisqu'il y a une plainte qui a été
déposée par une jeune femme de
17 ans lors d'un commissariat parisien
et donc c'est là raconte qu'elle a été
en contact avec lui enfin elle elle ne
savait pas elle croyait que c'était
Justine et effectivement il lui a
demandé de d'avoir si elle l'a dérangé
d'avoir des relations sexuelles
tarifiées donc là il va se faire dans
cette mois on va attendre qu'il y a un
drame pour pour enfin sauf s'il y a
d'autres dossier mais là la prison ne
sert à rien dans ce cas-là en fait il
pourra en faire 10 ans alors il est
inscrit au fichier des délinquants
sexuels et ce qu'il faut se demander là
aujourd'hui c'est si ce prédateur
puisque c'est un prédateur Guillaume
vient de de révéler tout ce qu'il a fait
sur Internet n'aurait pas récidivé et là
effectivement ça poserait la question
moi j'étais pour qu'il soit libéré à
l'époque je l'avais dit mais ça poserait
la question de Quesada finalement
peut-il se réinsérer un jour alors
est-ce qu'il n'est pas un prédateur qui
va recommencer en permanence voilà